Nerds,
nerds,
nerds.
Wait,
what's that?
A hipster.
Get outta here.
Hipster.
What comes to your mind when you think of the word nerd?
Depending on your generation,
a nerve could be someone who is socially inept,
awkward,
unattractive,
or intelligent,
bold,
and even cool.
The word nerd seems to have undergone a semantic change in recent years as
nerdiness has become part of the popular culture,
but what are the origins of the word nerd?
No one actually knows.
Wait,
what will,
but there are some theories though,
and today we're going to discuss two of the most likely origins of this very
peculiar word.
Though there are many other theories.
Their earliest recorded use of the word as we spell it today is found in a Dr
Seuss book published in 1951 called if I ran the zoo.
The book is recorded from the perspective of Gerald McGrew who would find way
more exotic animals to put in the zoo if he ran it.
I'm one of this fanciful journeys to the land of Ca.
True.
Gerald tells us that he would bring back an it catch a Pre Ben approved a
knuckle,
a nerd and a seersucker to,
yeah,
a nerd looking at the illustration.
One could imagine that this little creature truly is a stereotypical nerd.
He seemed somewhat removed and antisocial,
yet intelligent and given the fact that this is the first written account that
we have with the word,
it could be in fact be its origin.
There's a major flaw with this theory.
However,
the Oxford English dictionary listen instance of nerve found in a Newsweek
article dated the 8th of October,
1951 which states in Detroit,
someone who once would be called a drip or a square is now regrettably a nerd.
Is it possible that scarcely a year after the publication of a children's book
that offensible invention of Dr Seuss really inspired the Youth of Detroit to
start referring to squares as nerds?
Maybe though it seems somewhat unlikely.
Another possible origin though there seems to be little evidence to support it
is from a backsliding of the word drunk spelling nerd.
As far as the meeting goes,
this seems like a more likely origin.
Since the cool kids were those who like to get drunk and the uncool kids were
those who abstained.
It affected the exact opposite of drunks.
Nerds besides the missing k.
The main problem with this theory is that the end you are dispelling doesn't
appear until the sixties and seventies one to two decades after the Newsweek
article,
which spelled it and e r.
D.
This to me suggests one of two possibilities.
Either the writers in the 1950s didn't know the drunk to nerd origin and
therefore spelled it wrong,
or the drunk Tinder origin came as a folk etymology and the 1960s which altered
the spelling,
though not for very long as n e r d eventually won out.
So one of the word comes from a funny would be zoo animal.
In the world of Dr Seuss or from drunk spelled backwards nerve.
I've certainly come a long way from their antisocial,
awkward beginnings.
Tell the next time,
don't forget to be awesome.